bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo toute l'actualité politique et
parlementaire résumé en 45 minutes avec
mme moracchini bonjour jean miquel et
bonjour à tous et on commence cette
semaine dans l'actualité
europe ecologie les verts au congrès
quinze jours avant les primaires du
parti nicolas hulot at il commis sa
première erreur au cours d'un dîner avec
des journalistes il avoué avoir voulu
former un ticket avec jean louis borloo
il n'en fallait pas plus à sa rivale eva
joly pour se faire une santé
l'ump s'en prend au rsa il y avait cette
semaine une convention sur la justice
sociale
l'idée est de faire travailler 5 heures
par semaine les bénéficiaires du système
le père du rsa martin hirsch était
présent à la convention à content
ambiance enfin quand on reparle du
machisme à l'assemblée de femmes députés
de la majorité ont organisé cette
semaine une journée de la jupe pour
montrer que l'assemblée n'est pas
forcément l'endroit le plus macho
réactions dans les couleurs et avec nous
pour commenter cette actualité yannick
jadot bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur
ce plateau vous êtes député européen
membre d'europe écologie les verts
en 2008 vous étiez directeur des
campagnes de greenpeace france et plus
et dave décidé de rejoindre le mouvement
de cohn bendit pour les européennes un
passage du militantisme à la politique
qui vous a réussi puisque vous avez été
élu en 2009 député européen et au sein
d'europe écologie les verts vous êtes
toujours à proche de daniel cohn bendit
en ce qui concerne les primaires qui ont
commencé avec deux débats à cette
semaine vous soyez vous avez choisi
votre camp vous êtes porte parole d'eva
joly
vous dites que vous préférez sur une
écologie de combat plutôt que l'écologie
de pédagogie de nicolas hulot
alors vous allez nous expliquer dans un
instant ce que vous entendez par là l'on
va voir d'abord ce qui s'est passé le
week-end dernier au congrès de la
rochelle en ce début de semaine
on commente abondamment une petite
phrase malheureuse de nicolas hulot
cela s'est donc passé au congrès
d'europe écologie les verts cécile
duflot est triomphalement réélu à la
tête du parti votre ami daniel cohn
bendit est absent danny wood at on dit
mais ce qui va occuper les médias
c'est la petite phrase de nicolas hulot
qui raconte qu'il a envisagé une époque
un tandem avec jean-louis borloo
évidemment ça n'a pas plu jérémy
hartmann 1 ce devait être le sacre de
cécile duflot et ça l'a été samedi soir
c'est une secrétaire nationale d'europe
écologie les verts
très émue qui est réélu à 93% par les
militants mais ce plébiscite est passée
au second plan
non pas à cause de l'absence de daniel
cohn-bendit au congrès mais plutôt
éclipsé par la présence de nicolas hulot
et surtout de sa petite phrase adressée
la veille à des journalistes lors d'un
dîner le candidat aux primaires
écologistes qui avouait avoir envisagé
un partenariat avec jean-louis borloo
pour la présidentielle alors maladresse
de ce tout jeune converti en politique
ou stratégie pour élargir l'électorat
écologiste en tout cas eva joly sa
principale concurrente au poste de
présidentiable n'a pas manqué
d'exploiter les propos de nicolas hulot
pour moi il n'est pas possible dans des
sachets une alliance avec monsieur
borloo mais sur bordeaux à vos l'idée
venir le première sarkosyste eva joly
affiche clairement la couleur
face à un nicolas hulot sommé de
s'expliquer sur ses véritables
intentions
en l'état c'est même pas imaginable jean
louis borloo fait partie de la majorité
et il n'y a pas de compatibilité entre
les valeurs défendues par les
écologistes et les valeurs défendues aux
deux par la majorité
donc voilà mais si demain ce soit jean
louis borloo qui que ce soit moi c'est
ça je vous comprends est-ce qu'on
interdit définitivement aux gens
d'évoluer et de changer je pense pas que
ça soit le cas et l'esprit d'europe
écologie les verts lever l'ambiguïté
tout en affichant ses différences
exercice d'équilibriste pour l'ex
animateur d'ushuaïa ce matin à la radio
jean louis borloo confirme sa proximité
de points de vue avec nicolas hulot
chacun suit son chemin chacun est dans
ses accords éventuels ou dans ses
convictions mais cette idée de peser sur
le destin de son propre pays oui on l'a
pour la partager on partage ce soir à
toulouse aura lieu le premier débat
entre les candidats aux primaires
écologistes
un débat qui tombe à point nommé pour y
voir plus clair dans la nébuleuse europe
ecologie les verts alors yannick jadot
on a entendu nicolas hulot se défendre
est-ce que ça par un côté sympathique
finalement de considérer que la cause
écologiste transcende les partis et
qu'on peut très bien aller regarder du
côté de la droite
si on prend le bilan du gouvernement et
de la majorité ne se sarkozy non on peut
pas être dans la confusion si vous
voulez on pouvait imaginer en 2007 que
le lancement du grenelle de
l'environnement cette négociation avec
tous les acteurs les associations les
syndicats auxquels j'ai participé était
quelque chose de nouveau et de très
positif d'ailleurs c'était pas les
décisions du grenelle n'ont pas été une
plateforme écologistes mais c'était un
compromis entre différents acteurs et ça
montrait que les solutions écologistes
était rationnel du point de vue collège
économique
et puis rationnelle positif du point de
vue social le problème c'est que le
président de la république lui-même à
détricoter les résultats du grenelle que
le ministre borloo n'a rien trouvé à
redire quand le président de la
république a dit l'environnement ça
commence à bien faire et que finalement
ce ministre borloo numéro deux du
gouvernement voulant devenir le premier
ministre du président sarkozy au moment
juste après le discours de grenoble est
quand même un discours de rupture dans
la vision sarkozyste de la france il n'y
a pas de compatibilité avec les valeurs
d'europe écologie c'est ça qu'on a voulu
exprimer
la question n'est pas une question
d'ouverture et de fermeture c'est une
question de de cohérence sur les valeurs
sur les politiques publiques qui sont
menées europe écologie est ouvert s'il
ya des déçus du sarkozysme
les déçus du centrisme qui veulent
rejoindre europe écologie bienvenus mais
faut que ce soit clair par rapport au
combat que nous menons est clair par
rapport à la critique du pouvoir en
place
s'il n'y a pas ça on ne sait plus de
l'ouverture ça s'appelle de la confusion
et on revient sur cette idée qui a été
porté par les grandes entreprises et par
la droite qui est de dire 'voilà
l'écologie ne doit être ni de gauche ni
de droite c'est un supplément d'âme que
doivent acquérir tous les partis
politiques non nous portons une rupture
trop forte pour que ce soit simplement
un supplément d'âme
yannick jadot seulement c'est un petit
peu haro sur nicolas hulot on l'a vu
lors du deuxième débat jeudi soir qui
opposait les quatre candidats à la
primaire je vous propose d'écouter cet
échange on ne repart juste après une
vraie émotion par rapport à ce qu'on
peut appeler un problème est que je
nommerais directement le problème
hulot évidemment est il besoin de le
dire il n'y a pas d' attaques
personnelles il ya un problème politique
et 100% politique
donc c'est quelqu'un qui nous arrive de
la planète tf1 et dans l'image est
indissociable de celle des
multinationales qui ont été ses mécènes
pendant des années nous avons devant
nous une gidir est une occasion
historique
on a choisi soit justement de continuer
à participer à la petite histoire soin
d'écrire ensemble la grande histoire de
l'écologie politique et pardon de vous
le dire mais moi c'est vraiment ce à
quoi je veux participer avec vous
yannick jadot vous avez pensé quoi de
cet échange de ce débat vous avez
l'impression que ce pacte de non
agression qui avait été mise en place a
volé en éclats oui bien sûr moi je me
dis ce site un des plus beaux de
stéphane lange déplore ce type de 2,2
de propos parce que on est là pour
débattre on est là pour donner aussi aux
français des grilles de lecture des
propositions écologistes sur les
questions économiques sur les questions
sociales sur les questions de politique
étrangère et que là ça focalise le débat
sur la personne
nicolas hulot et c'est certainement pas
le coeur de la primaire de l'écologie
vous aviez mentionné en introduction de
cette émission les visions différentes
que portait nicolas hulot et eva joly
avait dit moi c'est s'agit contre
militantisme expliqué nous un peu parce
que j'ai pas dit pedro pédagogique
nicolas hulot revendique lui-même une
écologie de la pédagogie qui
consisterait à dénoncer expliquait
proposer tout à fait d'accord avec cette
dimension là vous aimez le combat eva
joly et non simplement il faire de la
politique il ya une dimension
supplémentaire qui est la responsabilité
de l'arbitrage
quand vous êtes quand vous avez milité
pour l'écologie vous savez parfaitement
que la question du nucléaire aujourd'hui
77% des français veulent sortir du
nucléaire
est ce que le président de la république
veut sortir du nucléaire non il veut
continuer à en vendre encore plus sur
les ogm
vous avez 80 90 % des français qui ont
toujours été opposés aux ogm
et pourtant non mais laissez moi vous
pour comprendre et pourtant le
gouvernement a été contraint d'avancer
sur les ogm et de poser un moratoire
pourquoi parce que au-delà de
l'explication
au delà il y à un moment où il faut
savoir combattre un certain nombre de
puissances qui sont les puissances les
lobbys des semenciers lobby la fns a le
lobby du nucléaire ou des déchets et il
faut savoir c'est ça la politique
intérieure
joli nenê n'est guère plus n'a pas de
passé de militante écologiste eva joly a
passé étant son parcours 30 ans de sa
vie à combattre des puissances très
forte qui était opposé à l'intérêt
général
ça fait trois ans à les membres allaient
fondatrice d'europe écologie avec dany
cohn-bendit avec josé bové avait que des
personnes comme moi et elle a porté
depuis aussi ce combat écolo au
parlement européen donc elle sait ce que
c'est que d'être responsables politiques
d'avoir à arbitrer entre des intérêts
qui peuvent être différents un petit mot
voire divergents et c'est ça l'écologie
de combat
aujourd'hui on n'imposera pas hier par
exemple nicolas hulot a dit moi je veux
réconcilier les riches et les pauvres
eh ben je pense qu'on n'aurait consignes
pas les riches et les pauvres on
réconcilie front réconcilier les
français autour de la justice sociale
c'est ça la différence il oppose c'est
cela qui nous différencie très vite un
petit mot de daniel cohn bendit que vous
citiez dont vous êtes très proche il dit
lui qu'il ne faut pas de candidat
écologiste pour 2012 que ça aurait été
bien de s'effacer derrière un candidat
socialiste en négociant pour les
législatives il fait pas un peu un
travail de sape votre votre ami non il
fait pas un travail de sape
dany cohn-bendit au moment des
régionales donc ça fait un peu plus d'un
an avait effectivement évoqué cette idée
négocions avec les socialistes pour
avoir un grand groupe parlementaire un
bon accord de gouvernement une bonne
participation gouvernement parce que la
pérennité de l'écologie politique
s'inscrit dans un groupe charnière au
parlement à l'assemblée nationale
maintenant nous savons est lui même le
sait aujourd'hui que il faut une
candidature écologiste pour peser y
compris changer d'avis les dit récemment
il s'interroge non il dit parce je veux
pas de candidature écologiste il dit je
m'interroge sur l'espace qui arrivera à
conquérir
eva joly ou nicolas hulot elle le
préparer des législatives n'est de toute
façon on est tous d'accord là dessus
simplement pour avoir un bon accord sur
les législatives pour avoir un bon
accord au gouvernement et convaincre les
français qu'ils sont pas tous convaincu
encore que nos solutions économiques ou
sociales sont très bonnes il faut une
candidature écologiste
parce que c'est le débat politique
majeur dans ce pays lundi encore yannick
jadot dominique strauss kahn a plaidé
non coupable
audience expresse à manhattan 7 minutes
le temps pour le juge de lire l'acte
d'accusation à l'extérieur du tribunal
un autre accueil l'attendaient des
femmes de chant ou en tenues venu
soutenir celle qui accuse dominique
strauss kahn écouté les avocats des deux
parties dominique strauss kahn a décidé
de plaider non coupable est une
déclaration forte et éloquente
nous pensons qu'il n'y a pas d'élément
fort prouvant la contrainte dans cette
affaire toute suggestion du contraire
n'est tout simplement pas crédible
elle se bat pour garder sa dignité
elle tient bon pour toutes les femmes et
tous les enfants qui ont été victimes
d'agressions sexuelles et qui n'osent
pas porter plainte
c'est une femme très courageuse yannick
jadot le voit à présent tous les coups
seront permis pour dans ce procès qui
augure dans quelques mois de dominique
strauss kahn c'est la justice américaine
c'est un mot de commentaire c'est assez
glauque
on a tous été choqués par la violence de
l'attaqué contre dominique strauss kahn
et qu'il y est des images quand il a été
arrêté ont maintenant on va être choqué
par la violence des attaques de la
défense qui va chercher à mettre en
pièces
une femme qui visiblement une victime
incontestablement une victime et on voit
aussi le décalage entre le temps
médiatique où on nous en a fait des tas
et des tas et des tas toute la journée
pour habib sûr beaucoup trop vous savez
les chaînes d'information permanente les
journaux tout ça pour avoir une phrase
campus n'a pas été filmée donc on est
sur un temps médiatique qui n'a rien à
voir avec le temps judiciaire
mais je crois que l'événement de cette
journée là vous l'avez dit c'est la
manifestation des femmes de chambre des
invisibles qui ont dix corps est une
opération de communication du fed
c'est pas bien interprété ça comme ça je
crois qu'on a dans notre société
toute une série de professions qui sont
considérés ou qui se considèrent comme
des invisibles
relisez le bouquin de florence aubenas
elle raconte la même chose
toutes ces femmes de ménage qui sont des
invisibles à qui on dit pas bonjour qui
sont dans des camps des conditions de
travail
terrible et je crois que si l' affaire
strauss kahn pouvaient aboutir à un
débat sur l'humiliation notamment
l'humiliation des femmes que ce soit
dans leur vie professionnelle ou dans
leur vie privée qui était quand même
globalement un sujet tabou on verra bien
ouverts mais quand même avec un certain
nombre de roland qui sont pas à la
hauteur de l'importance de ce débat dans
notre société
allez on passe au mardi avec à l'arrivée
l'assemblée duper la river pardo du plfr
un nom barbare qu'on vous explique tout
de suite
le plfr projet de loi de finances
rectificative un texte qui règlent les
derniers ajustements concernant les
impôts qui touche le patrimoine
s'étaient déjà annoncé le bouclier
fiscal est supprimé en revanche l'impôt
sur la fortune est très léger au total
c'est encore un cadeau aux riches estime
l'opposition
chaude ambiance dans l'hémicycle en ce
mardi chloé buffard des socialistes très
offensive sur la fiscalité pas moins de
six questions sur ce thème
pouvez vous expliquer simplement aux
français
votre conception de la justice merci de
les quitter
alors vous me demandez quel est notre
notion de la justice sociale et de la
justice fiscale mais moi je vais vous
parler de la vôtre parce qu' est-ce que
vous avez pris des mesures contre les
paradis fiscaux
jamais est-ce que vous avez pris des
mesures contre les stock options
jamais on entend le parti socialiste
dénonce et les riches mais sur cette
question je vais vous dire vous êtes
peut-être croyants mais vous n'êtes pas
pratiquants et l'actualité de la montre
françois baroin et les députés de la
majorité prennent ensuite le relais
ils n'ont qu'un mot à la bouche la
réforme est juste presque un slogan de
campagne ce qui vous gêne dans cette
réforme c'est sa justice c'est son
équilibre ce sont des kits et une
majorité unie en apparence du moins
certains députés ump ont déposé un
amendement pour inclure dans l' isf les
oeuvres d'art mais refus catégorique de
françois fillon alors yannick jadot je
m'adresse là-haut porte-parole d'eva
joly
on fait quoi pour taxer les plus riches
imaginons une alliance avec le ps vous
arriver au pouvoir
on fait quoi on garde les sf tel qu'il
est en l'état avant la réforme
on refait tout et on taxe les revenus du
capital que fait-on diab 2 oui rappelez
la question vous posez des questions
auxquelles répond en 30 secondes
j'ai quand même essayé on a en france
aujourd'hui c'est prouvé par les études
plus on est riche moins
proportionnellement on paye d'impôts
donc impôts et profondément inégale et
on a en france en moyenne 1 euro hérité
ou obtenues par le patrimoine est 2,5
fois moins taxés qu'un euro gagné quand
vous avez un métier
donc il faut absolument arriver à
recréer de la progressivité forte sur
l'impôt vous savez que nous défendons un
revenu maximal l'idée d'un revenu
maximal qui serait autour de 40 fois le
revenu médian au-delà duquel l'impôt est
proche d'un impôt confiscatoire
il faut le dire donc on recrée fortement
à 100% à partir de là voilà ce qu'avait
fait roosevelt après la crise financière
des années 30 on n'est pas dans une
logique soviétique
c'est ce qu'ont fait des états unis
pendant extrêmement longtemps c'est
reagan qui a cassé cette logique d'un
impôt très progressif aux états unis et
il faut avoir surtout à l'impôt à partir
du moment où vous avez un impôt qui
prend en compte les revenus mais aussi
les revenus du capital
les revenus du patrimoine que cet impôt
est très progressif
on peut revoir liesse f
mais aujourd'hui ce qui touche beaucoup
d'argent soit par leurs salaires leurs
revenus soit par le patrimoine où les
droits de succession de tout le pays
quasiment pas ou peu d'impôts c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut revenir mais on
sortira pas la france de ces questions
de déficit et d'endettement
si on revoit pas aussi la fiscalité sur
les entreprises les tpe très petites
entreprises payent en moyenne 33 %
d'impôt sur les bénéfices les pme 22%
les entreprises du cac 40 lui pour cent
on est dans le système inverse de ce qu
il faudrait faire plus on a de bénéfices
plus il faudrait payer d'impôts là
encore remettre de la l'équité de
l'égalité face à l'impôt et surtout de
la progressivité et les gâteaux mardi
toujours on va parler des élections
sénatoriales qui auront lieu en
septembre prochain
on croyait la foudre passé mais
l'ambiance au sein de la droite
parisienne tourne à l'orage objet du
litige encore et toujours la validation
des listes la commission d'investiture
de l'ump a pourtant validé ces liste
menée par chantal jouanno pas de quoi
calmer la fronde des élus parisiens la
bataille de paris ne fait que commencer
jérôme ramier
la guerre est déclarée pour les
sénatoriales dans la droite parisienne
malgré la liste officielle investi hier
par l'ump des élus parisiens s'insurge
contre ce choix
en cause l'éviction de cette liste de
pierre charon ancien conseiller
politique de nicolas sarkozy
six maires ump d'arrondissement sur huit
prenez sa candidature mais c'est un
proche de françois fillon qui occupera
sa place sur la liste ump
maintenant que la liste est investi par
le parti le débat est clos pour les
heureux élus s unissent qui rassemble
des sortants comme moi même
une ministre qui conduit la liste qui
était souhaité par le président de la
république donc pour moi c'est la bonne
liste
j'en ai un petit peu à 7 c est lui qui
veulent absolument forcer la main il
faut convaincre c'est ça qui est
important politiquement en tout cas
c'est ce que j'entends faire et j'espère
qu'on va y arriver avec 7 10 et si les
sénatoriales sont les prochaines
élections ce sont aussi les législatives
de 2012 et les municipales de 2014 qui
sont en ligne de mire des différents
camps avec l'arrivée possible de
françois fillon dès 2012 dans la
capitale une question prématurée pour
certains je crois que le scrutin qui
compte aujourd'hui c'est les
sénatoriales
après c'est le scrutin essentiel de la
présidence de la république
après viendra les législatives et les
municipales c'est une autre histoire et
c'est dans pas mal de temps des
sénatoriales qui servent donc à chaque
conte pour s'armer en vue de futures
échéances
un jeu dangereux qui pourrait faire
perdre un ou deux sièges à la droite
sur les cinq qu'elle compte actuellement
dans la capitale des sièges qui pourrait
également compter dans la bataille de la
droite pour conserver le sénat en
septembre l'année jadot vous avez des
candidats également d'europe écologie
les verts pour les sénatoriales
on compte quatre sénateurs verts en ce
moment est ce que vous pensez qu'il y en
aura plus
jean vincent placé qui est numéro deux
d'europe écologie est bien placé et tête
de liste dans l'essonne notamment on
espère l'objectif initial c'est d'avoir
un groupe mais on espère monter à 10 ou
oui ça s'est mis à forte peut-être
quelques alliances à trouver après mais
là c'est la cuisine du sénat sur lequel
je suis pas experte mais on espère on
espère évidemment accroître sensiblement
le nombre de sénateurs
vous savez qu'on n'a pas beaucoup d'élus
historiquement a vu le mode de scrutin
de grands électeurs donc c'est
évidemment on a un rattrapage à mener en
terme de représentativité dans les
grandes instances type sénat où vous
êtes souvent associé au groupe
socialiste notamment ici au sénat ça
augure aussi des prochaines alliances
pour les législatives pour les
sénatoriales avec les élus socialistes
on a un accord électoral a passé
évidemment que ce soit là on a passé un
accord sur les sénatoriales
il faudra qu'un accord sur les
législatives c'est donc c'est en bonne
voie oui alors forcément l'actualité du
parti socialiste notre actualitté
interne le congrès la primaire ont
reporté un peu les échéances mais l'idée
de geler un certain nombre de
circonscriptions d'ici la fin de l'été
au début au début de l'automne
parce qu'on sait que vu le nombre de
circonscriptions à geler si on le fait
pas assez tôt après on aura beaucoup de
mal à déloger un certain nombre de
candidats socialistes qui se trouveront
qui se pencheront très légitime
évidemment rapport de force comme
d'habitude allez hop on passe au
mercredi quand l'ump s'en prend au rsa
en ce mercredi l'ump se réunit donc pour
une convention sur la justice sociale au
menu surtout les changements à apporter
au rsa le revenu de solidarité active
il s'agit d'imposer à ses bénéficiaires
cinq heures de travail hebdomadaire
rémunérer le martin le matin même martin
hirsch père du rsa avait fait entendre
son mécontentement julien le caureq ce
matin le père du revenu de solidarité
active lance un pavé dans la mare
accusant l'état de détourner un milliard
d'euros venant d'une taxe censée
financer le rsa
des propos aussitôt démentie avec
virulence par le gouvernement monsieur
hirsch et vous-même utilisant les mêmes
arguments ressort proféré une sottise un
mensonge une contre-vérité cet après
midi malgré l'ambiance électrique
martin hirsch a souhaité venir défendre
son projet et avant d'entrer dans la
salle
il enfonce le clou on n'a pas à
saint-just riez comme cela une leçon
voilà donc moi j'ai beaucoup d'estimé
pour françois baroin j'ai déjà discuté
dans son bureau de cette question
d'excédent je pense que tout le monde
sait qu effectivement
la dépense est moins grande ce qui a été
prévu ce qui permet à l'état de donner
une subvention plus faible et je pense
qu'on a le droit et le devoir de poser
la question de cet argent
mais le plus virulent c'était le
secrétaire général de l'ump jean
françois copé qui n'apprécie pas
vraiment les allégations de l'ex membre
du gouvernement quand il fait des
amalgames entre lisf d'une part et
d'autre part ce que toute la réforme que
nous mettons en oeuvre depuis trois ans
sur le rsa oui mélanger les choses
exprès mais c'est classique c'est dans
le c'est toujours comme ça que ça se
passe quand on met l'idéologie avant
lille avant le le pragmatisme et la
réalité du quotidien
retour à la salle pour le discours
rapide mais très attendu de martin
hirsch fin du match avec une dernière
amabilités au micro jean françois copé a
voulu montrer qu'il avait le dernier mot
ce concept avec plusieurs que demain est
d'accord avec nous donc c'est tout ça
pour ça comme dit la chanson
voilà tout ça pour ça l'arrivée restera
donc cinq heures de travail rémunéré
obligatoire pour le rsa socle
vous qui êtes député européen est ce que
le rsa est une exception française
le fait qu'on instaure un revenu minimum
pour les plus déshérités un complément
de revenu pour ceux qui gagnent très peu
c'est pas une exception européenne
mais là où on est dans l'exception
européenne c'est la très faible qualité
en france de l'accompagnement des
chômeurs on est maintenant sur des
statistiques à pôle emploi un
responsable pour 300 chômeurs et ça
c'est des choses que vous ne retrouvez
pas dans le reste de l'europe et six
cliniques aussi en france la difficulté
à remettre de la rigueur dans le travail
et c'est ça la la la ce qui est terrible
dans ce débat monsieur copé parle
de dogmatisme ou d'idéologie jeudi ils
ont tapé ce gouvernement a tapé sur
l'assistanat l'oise yves t bref les ceux
qui bénéficient du rsa qui est quand
même extrêmement faible vous n'arrivez
pas à vivre sérieusement avec ça c'est
extrêmement difficile
donc on a tapé sur le fait que ce sont
des profiteurs pour finalement avoir un
débat qui va être complètement détournée
sur comment on accompagne à l'insertion
professionnelle et c'est ça le vrai je
vois est ce que ces cinq heures de
madame ne sont pas fous que finalement
une façon de de réintroduire parce que
vous non mais celui d'écouter climat en
europe c'est la qualité de
l'accompagnement c'est le fait que vous
ayez un conseiller qui vous aide et
psychologiquement parfois parce que
c'est très difficile et surtout
professionnellement à retrouver du
travail
il y a rien comme modèle sur la
réinsertion notamment évidemment
toujours les pays nordiques parce que il
ya qui l 2 me avant unis a de ce point
de vue là un d'un vrai service public de
l'accompagnement au retour à l'emploi
la cinq heures où on considère que c'est
sérieux notamment les services à la
personne qui sont pointés dans cet
exercice sur les personnes âgées dont il
faut aider l'autonomie sur certains
services publics
vous imaginez que vous allez prendre un
chômeur et lui dire pendant cinq heures
tu vas aller faire du civisme en
banlieue duval a sevran il faut des gens
formés pour faire ça il faut des gens
dire ça devient un vrai métier parce
qu'on a besoin de médiation dans cette
société
on a besoin de davantage de services
publics mais il faut des gens qualifiés
dont ça devient un métier et non pas des
chômeurs dont on va dire tu es oisifs et
donc on va te faire bosser cinq heures
pour te montrer qu'on n'est pas là pour
te donner de l'argent cadeaux tout ça
est en baissant les bénéficiaires du rsa
mais pas le chauffard non tout à fait
mais je veux dire les bénéficiaires du
rsa socle dont vous parlez sont des
chômeurs ils sont inscrits à pôle emploi
donc on est sur un système où
globalement on veut diviser les français
on est encore dans la stratégie 2007
ceux qui se lèvent tôt et ceux qui
passent leur temps à boire des canons et
regarder la télé oui je crois
malheureusement que ça va être un thème
de fou campagne on voit bien la sécurité
on voit bien la stigmatisation des
français issus de l'émigration des
résidents étrangers et on voit
aujourd'hui il revenir
cette stigmatisation de ceux qui n'ont
pas d'emploi
ces gens là il faut les aider il faut
arrêter les matraquer jeudi de nouvelles
mesures et des annonces de nicolas
sarkozy pour venir en aide aux victimes
de la sécheresse en ce jeudi donc
nicolas sarkozy a choisi les terres de
poitou charentes pour annoncer des
mesures concernant la sécheresse
la présidente de région ségolène royal
qui n'était pas conviée s'est invitée
d'elle-même ce qui a donné lieu à une
image de poignées de main et un petit
échange de questions-réponses sur le
fond nicolas sarkozy a annoncé un report
d'un an des remboursements d'emprunts il
a exclu en revanche des aides directes
un peu plus tard françois fillon devant
les sénateurs cette fois ci a précisé le
montant des aides consenties aux
éleveurs on écoute
il s'agit maintenant de mettre en oeuvre
une solidarité nationale directe à
l'égard des agriculteurs et je ne sais
pas où vous avez entendu qu'il n'y
aurait pas d' aides directes
c'est près d'un milliard d'euros que la
solidarité nationale va devoir consacrer
au soutien de nos agriculteurs avec une
petite cacophonie à la tête de l'état
sur aides directes pas être direct
nicolas sarkozy les avait exclues en dix
ans ne retombons pas dans les mauvaises
habitudes de vous donner des allocations
qui seraient déclarées illégales donc on
suppose par l'europe
elle a par bruxelles c'est vous
confirmer qu'effectivement une aide
directe aujourd'hui serait impossible et
que bruxelles n'est pas forcément ça
dépend quand vous avez une vraie
sécheresse et que vous pouvez justifier
de la calamité vous pouvez obtenir
l'autorisation des aides directes
dernièrement si les agriculteurs sont
obligés de rembourser c'est parce que le
gouvernement a mal travaillé
le gouvernement a mal déclaré c aide à
l'europe et se retrouve en infraction
plus sur la forme que sur le fond
ce qui est terrible dans ce qui est
10 par le président la république c'est
qu'il dit solidarité nationale moi j'ai
pas de souci avec ça à partir du moment
où les agriculteurs font face à on va
avoir des baisses de production de 30 à
50% sur les céréales c'est terrible vous
avez les éleveurs qui sont en train de
décapitaliser qui essayent de vent de
brader leur bétail donc il faut les
aider mais solidarité il doit y avoir
déjà au sein de la filière lait là le
crédit agricole va encore faire de
l'argent sur cette crise
les assureurs font de l'argent sur cette
crise l'agroalimentaire de la grande
distribution ne contribue pas à cette
solidarité donc faudrait déjà qu'ils
aient une solidarité de filières et puis
à ce moment là une solidarité à tout le
monde
m quand tout le monde contribue parce
que finalement que ce soit quand
l'agriculture va bien tous les acteurs
font de l'argent et quand l'agriculture
va mal se sont que les producteurs qui
sont les principales victimes
les autres continuent à bien aller donc
ça ça n'est pas normal tout le monde
devrait contribuer mais avant les
contribuables déjà les acteurs de la
filière et ce qui est dommage dans ce
que dit nicolas sarkozy c'est qu'il dit
et bien donc on va relâcher les
contraintes sur les retenues d'eau les
retenues d'eau sont une des causes de
les problèmes que rencontrent les
agriculteurs vous avez en poitou
charentes structurellement des problèmes
d'eau et vous avez beaucoup de maïs
irrigué et ce maïs irrigué et totalement
aujourd'hui incompatibles avec la
ressource en eau et le fait qu'on a
réchauffé en climatique et qu'on va
avoir ce type d'événement de plus en
plus fréquents donc au lieu de changer
de modèle et d'avoir un modèle de
production qui scelle la moitié de l'eau
dès que vous faites un peu de
polyculture que vous faites davantage de
fourrage vous contribuez à résoudre ce
type de problème puisque disaient les
agriculteurs hier notamment c'est que ça
ne donnera pas à manger à leurs bêtes
les mesures qu'il faut par exemple ce
que ne fait pas le président sarkozy il
faut plafonner le le le la tonnes de
fourrage à 150 euros c'est ce que
demande la plupart des éleveurs
on est aujourd'hui à 400 euros alors que
d'habitude c'est 100 110 euros
il faut plafonner il faut aider les
agriculteurs mais de manière ponctuelle
et structurelles sinon on confirme un
modèle qui est à bout de souffle ayeni
j'adore parlant des agriculteurs
si une autre crise celle des producteurs
de fruits et légumes liés à la bactérie
en allemagne notamment une trentaine de
morts aujourd'hui une origine toujours
inconnue même si on a appris aujourd'hui
que les graines notamment les graines
germées étaient à l'origine de ce
problème au parlement européen
vous l'avez peut-être vu sur cette image
il y a eu ce député pagnol brandissant
un concombre fustigeant la précipitation
et l'imprudence de l'allemagne comme la
mauvaise gestion européenne
vous aussi vous diriez que l'europe n'a
pas su gérer cette crise de cette
épidémie
c'est extrêmement compliqué ce type de
crise parce que quand vous n'avez aucune
donnée réelle sur l'origine de la
bactérie et que vous avez un soupçon qui
était là le concombre si évidemment
aujourd'hui tous les producteurs de
concombres se sont trouvé extrêmement
fragilisé est directement impactée par
le fait qu'on est tous disent et le
concombre qui est potentiellement à
l'origine de ce drame
imaginons clairement pointée du doigt
l'espagne a été particulièrement pointés
du doigt et notamment les cultures du
sud de l'espagne qui sont ultra
intensive et qui sont une catastrophe
sociale environnementale mais ça c'est
pas le sujet mais imaginer que l'europe
ou que le gouvernement allemand parce
que c'est plus au gouvernement allemand
que l'europe pour le coup n'est pas et
dit c'est simplement un soupçon donc on
va pas en parler et que la bactérie soit
réellement venu du concombre et que vous
ayez eu 50 cent morts supplémentaires
on aurait accusé l'allemagne de ne pas
avoir ce soupçon sur l'ad sur la table
donc il faut cesser pas là aussi à
l'europe de s'emparer du problème et non
pas un pays
vous avez raison il faudrait qu'il y ait
au niveau européen surtout une
coordination beaucoup plus qu elle ne
sortait des aliments non c'est qu'il ya
une autorité européenne mais vous savez
qu'elle a été régulièrement critiqué
parce que souvent les dirigeants de l'
agence européenne à la sécurité des
aliments viennent de grands groupes
agroalimentaires ou semenciers donc ça
jette un trouble sur la qualité
l'expertisé européenne
il faut mettre en coordination beaucoup
plus rapide toutes les structures
nationales d' expertise et puis surtout
s'assurer qu'à ce moment là on est une
expertise indépendante
et puis dire les choses aux citoyens est
capable d'assumer que on a un doute
qu'on ne sait pas et que voilà ce qu'on
propose aux citoyens comme mesure face à
une crise dont on n'avait pas tous les
éléments
il ya peut-être aussi un travail à faire
avec les citoyens avec plus de
communication c'est que vous demander de
la transparence
il faut savoir dire aux citoyens mais
c'est extrêmement difficile il faut
savoir dire on un soupçon
on n'est pas sûr et voilà on est face à
une bactérie mickey il faut savoir
communiquer et pas simplement faire de
la sur-réaction on l'a vu un mot même de
son linceul et forcément on l'est vers
la grippe h1n1
on l'a vu sur tout ça il ya des jeux de
communication politique qui sait qu'ils
sont pas au service des citoyens qui
sont d'abord au service de la politique
où on l'a vu comme dans le cas de la
grippe h1n1 au service de grands groupes
pharmaceutiques
ces deux traverses sont à éviter jeudi
encore le sénat se penche sur le dossier
sensible du gaz de schiste
un vote en première lecture d'une
proposition de loi ump qui interdit la
technique de fracturation hydraulique
pour l'exploration et l'exploitation de
ce gaz
un texte jugé insuffisant par la gauche
les explications de mounir souci on le
croyait définitivement enterré le gaz de
schiste refait surface au sénat la
majorité laisse la porte ouverte à
l'utilisation de la très controversée
méthode d'extraction par fracturation
hydraulique mais uniquement dans le
cadre de la recherche
s'il ya une porte ouverte c'est vrai
tout simplement parce que quelque part
le gouvernement ou la majorité
voudraient je ne sais pas c'est pas un
procès d'intention mais voudraient s'y
engouffrer pour finalement comme au
départ comme lorsque
le père les permis ont été signés
pouvoir explorer et exploiter la méthode
par fracturation hydraulique serait à
l'origine de deux mini séisme en
angleterre au moment où le tout
nucléaire est remise en cause
renoncer par principe à cette ressource
pourrait peser sur la politique
énergétique nous avons semble-t-il la
possibilité d'avoir sous nos pieds
plusieurs décennies consommation de gaz
ou de pétrole et bien regardons ce que
nous pouvons en faire
l'hexagone abrite potentiellement la
deuxième réserve européenne derrière la
pologne le gaz comprimé sous la roche
pourrait couvrir au moins 60 ans de
notre consommation nationale en gaz les
intérêts des exploitants se trouve
contrarié par ce texte qui empêche de
forer à grande échelle
la gauche a réclamé l'abrogation
immédiate des permis d'exploration déjà
délivrés aux industriels pas si simple
pour le gouvernement l'abrogation des
permis à toute force c'est prendre un
risque financier considérable car cette
abrogé une autorisation administrative
en cas de rupture de contrat
les titulaires des permis pourrait se
retourner contre l'état alors yannick
jadot roque ler ont interdit la
fracturation hydraulique mais on laisse
la porte ouverte aussi à d'autres
techniques d'exploration peut-être
propre si elles existent vous au
contraire vous êtes sur une position il
fallait tout arrêter il faut il faut
abroger parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'existe
pas de techniques propres d'exploration
d'exploitation
ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas du gaz
de schiste
alors donc on va pas investir ou laisser
croire ou du cfa sont accordés une sorte
de moratoire à ceux qui veulent
exploiter le gaz de schiste que ce soit
le risque le risque il est
environnemental le risque de laisser
comme ça une porte ouverte à d'autres
méthodes
j'ai pas ce que vous avez à voir
évidemment on laissera probablement
passé 2012 c'est ce que veut faire total
ou c'est ce que veut faire la société
toréador
balkany avait comme avocat l'ami de jean
louis borloo peut être futur directeur
de campagne de jean louis borloo
mais tout ça ne pose pas de problème ni
europe écologie ni à personne d'autre
je plaisante et donc on est évidemment
eux ils espèrent pouvoir modifier dans
la présentation de leurs techniques
d'exploitation à ce titre on y voit la
modifier le titre et de tuyaux pour
prétendre or ce qui était interdit
mais dans ce qui pourrait être autorisée
mais sans rien changer aux dégâts
environnementaux et sanitaires la
sémantique pour la supporter over est
exactement ce qui est terrible là dedans
c'est que le gouvernement navigue entre
sa majorité et une opposition qui sa
majorité qui a changé question jacques
aubourg au départ voulait l'abrogation
même jean louis borloo suk avait signé
les permis avait dit après mais non il
faut les interdire
et puis finalement sont des permis qui
sont accordés à total et à monsieur
balkany donc tout ça visiblement leur
pose des problèmes donc nathalie
kosciusko morizet fait une sorte de deux
slaloms permanent entre des positions
contradictoires
sachant que l'opinion publique n'en veut
pas et moi quand j'entends que si on en
fini et que nucléaire il faut forcément
avoir du gaz c'est non alors il ya ni là
encore est ce que c'est pas il ne se
doit pas être une directive européenne
plutôt que sur sur l'interdiction
l'autorisation de l'exploration du gaz
de schiste c'est suffisamment important
en terme d'environnement pour qu'on
envisage vous avez raison ce qu'on
demande en permanence aux à la
commission européenne s'est dévaluée
là où il ya déjà de l'exploitation gaz
de schiste les conditions dans
lesquelles ça se réalise mais vous savez
scripting et de rock qui pratiquent
l'exploration de gaz là en pologne ils
sont en train de commencer
ils vont en faire un élément de leur
présidence qui démarre le 1er juillet
simplement la difficulté qu'on a sur
l'énergie au niveau européen c'est que
ça n'est pas une compétence européenne
dans le traité de lisbonne c'est un
échec de l'europe
tous les états ont dit notre politique
énergétique ça relève de la
responsabilité nationale
donc la seule obligation quant au niveau
européen c'est de faire 20 % d'énergies
renouvelables en moyenne dans l'europe
mais pour le reste du bouquet
énergétique ça relève de la compétence
des états donc la france peut continuer
à m c'est le voeu des centrales
nucléaires sur toutes ses frontières
sans que les états voisins puissent y
trouve à redire même si aujourd'hui ils
sont très critiques vis-à-vis de la
france sur ce point bon on veut terminer
cette émission a vraiment tout autre
chose
ce qu'on appelait la journée de la jupe
à l'assemblée
on sait que des députés femmes se sont
plaints du machisme qui règne dans
l'hémicycle et dans les couloirs et bien
cette semaine deux autres femmes députés
ump ont invité leurs consoeurs à venir
en jupe pour démontrer au contraire que
l'assemblée n'ait pas si macho en tout
cas peut-être au moins qu'ailleurs
mathilde terrier qui était pas conseillé
de venir en jupe dans cet établissement
parmi eux près de venir en jupe venir en
jupe
c'est aussi ce qu'on fait ce matin
valérie boyer et bérengère poletti
mais ici à l'assemblée c'est pour
prouver le contraire montrer qu'il n'y a
pas de machisme une mini-manifestation
auteurs genou après les témoignages de
députés femmes de tous bords et en
particulier celui de chantal jouanno qui
confié ne plus montrer ses jambes dans
l'hémicycle c'est mal défendre ces
jeunes filles dans les quartiers que de
réagir comme ça donc pas de dire
comporte pas du passé c'est n'importe
quoi
on est des femmes et on n'est pas plus
mal traités à l'assemblée nationale qu
ailleurs nous n'avons pas de remarques
déplacées en tout cas moi je n'en ai
jamais
essuyez et ça il faut quand même le
souligner que l'assemblée nationale est
malheureusement et je dis bien
malheureusement un des rares endroits en
france où les hommes et les femmes sont
payées de la même façon pas victime
égalitaire mais pour autant minoritaires
ici à l'assemblée seuls 18,5 pour cent
des élus sont des femmes
un univers peut-être pas matisse mais
extrêmement masculin où aujourd'hui
cette initiative laisse perplexe voire
désespère de la jupe ou ici et veulent
se mettre en jupe et peuvent se mettre
en jupe
j'espère qu'on ne demandera pas à nous
mettre en kilt je suis scandalisé par le
niveau que l'on veut traiter avec lequel
on veut traiter les problèmes politiques
aujourd'hui franchement c'est lamentable
lamentable dévoiler ses chevilles pour
montrer que les députés ne sont pas
macho pas forcément la garantie la mieux
choisi pour démontrer la liberté des
femmes dans ces couloirs
quand on sait qu'elles ont dû attendre
les années 80 pour avoir le droit de
porter un pantalon alors on disait tout
à l'heure que l' affaire dsk a posé
quelques questions notamment sur la
place des femmes là encore une
initiative au parlement européen il ya
30% de femmes c'est pas terrible non
plus c'est pas terrible mais c'est déjà
mieux
je crois qu'on a tous partis confondus
des efforts à faire en matière de
représentation on n'est pas mal placé
les écolos on est souvent le parti qui
joue le plus la parité mais je trouve
que cette façon de 2,2 de construire le
débat nécessaire dans ce pays sur
l'égalité de traitement entre les femmes
et les hommes sur le fait qu'il faut
avancer dans les conseils
d'administration sur le fait qu'il faut
avancer à tous les postes de
responsabilité
moi j'aime bien l'idée des quotas je
veux dire que c'est toujours très
compliqué mais je pense qu'à un moment
il faut faire bouger les choses et que
partout l'égalité des droits soient
reconnus on est quand même dans une
société qui aujourd'hui discrimine
énormément discrimine ces quartiers
discriminent les femmes discrimine les
jeunes discrimine les gens issus de
l'immigration
il faut qu'on arrive à voir ce débat
j'espère que ce sera un sujet clé de la
présidentielle parce qu'on ne on
appellera pas notre société si on
s'attaque pas profondément à la
discrimination est un pas en
revendiquant une égalité des chances
mais en défendant une égalité des droits
c'est là dessus qu'on vous termine notre
émission merci de nous avoir suivis
merci aux merci à la saison prochaine
merci beaucoup nous avons même prochaine
le gain de temps
l'information politique et parlementaire
en temps réel c'est sur l'application
iphone de public sénat